[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie heute zu einem minenfeld vom
thema nämlich der so genannten
identitätspolitik wobei ist nicht die
rede von einem minenfeld bereits ein
fauxpas aber jetzt sind wir mitten im
thema führt die identitätspolitik nur zu
sprechen verboten und treibt keine in
unserer gesellschaft wo es doch darum
ginge gerechtigkeit für alle zu wollen
oder lehrt uns identitätspolitik
rassismus diversität und sexismus
überhaupt erst zu sehen und ernst zu
nehmen
darüber spreche ich heute mit der
kulturwissenschaftlerin mit und sanieren
sie habe kürzlich den roman identität
vorgelegt da diese fragen mit viel
tiefenschärfe und humor angeht
herzlich willkommen sich freue mich
jetzt wollen ja frau sanja ich hab in
der anmoderation das thema
identitätspolitik aus minenfeld
gezeichnet erleben sie das auch so also
ich höre dass zumindest immer wieder das
ist also das wort das dafür immer wieder
verwendet wird ich glaube es ist beides
wir alle wollen eine gesellschaft mit
gerechtigkeit für alle haben
und die frage ist wie kommen wir da hin
und da haben wir unterschiedliche wege
und es ist ja auch interessant
identitätspolitik ist sozusagen das
reizwort der stunde aber eigentlich ist
es kein neuer begriff und
identitätspolitik gibt schon ganz lange
denken sie zum beispiel an die
kolonialzeit womit identitätspolitik
gerechtfertigt wurde das ist die oben
und die unten gibt und es eigentlich zur
explosion geführt hat absolut ist halt
die frage welche definition wir
verwenden ich würde dem zustimmen ich
würde auch sagen ganz klar da wurde eine
weiße rasse erfunden die gab es ja
vorher nicht also vor haben sich leute
über irland oder ihre sprache
identifiziert nicht über weiß sein und
und dadurch haben sie natürlich eine in
anführungszeichen unterlegene rasse
erfunden nämlich die schwarzen die
kolonisierten usw
aber das wort identitätspolitik ist ein
relativ neues tatsächlich in den 70er
jahren vom kombi river collective
erfunden worden geprägt worden die
gesagt haben wir sprechen für uns wir
machen identitätspolitik die haben das
aber ganz klar nicht ausschließen
gemeint als sollen sich der manifest
durchliest dann ist es halt wirklich wir
wollen sozialismus für alle wir wollen
gerechtigkeit für alle aber wir sind es
leid dass andere über entsprechendes die
das private ist politisch und so weiter
daher kommt es um was die beiden formen
von identitätspolitik gemeinsam haben
ist eben dieses sich beziehen auf die
gruppe wie wir schon gesagt haben im
einen fall wurde es verwendet um
abgrenzung vorzunehmen und
diskriminierung zu rechtfertigen und in
diesen neueren fall geht es sehr viel
mehr darum minderheiten sichtbar zu
machen und ihnen zur anerkennung zu
verhelfen
genau also es gibt ja dieses irgendwie
ich sehe keine hautfarben irgendwie
diesen berühmten satz und er bedeutet
halt in der regel ich sehe die
auswirkung von rassismus nicht
das ist ein riesiges problem aber
natürlich wollen wir alle irgendwann
dahin kommen dass wir wirklich sagen
naja hautfarben aha ist ja wie
schuhgröße oder so es gibt es natürlich
aber es ist ja nicht relevant glauben
sie gekommen da mal hin
ich bin mir relativ sicher dass also
gerade wenn man so ein bisschen
historisch guckt rassismus ist ein in
der form wie wir es kann ein relativ
neues phänomen in dieser vorne als diese
gedanken von menschen sind so wie sie
sind und können sich nicht ändern
modernes phänomen das irgendwie
historisch sind wir eigentlich in der
letzten phase in den todesdrohungen
dieser dieses verständnis die frage ist
was kommt danach also werden wir danach
uns irgendwie definieren
das finde ich jetzt interessante sie
sagen diese idee ist eine neue sozusagen
zu sagen ich bin so nicht anders weil
aber ist es nicht schon im mittelalter
dass man gesagt hat die oben nun die
unten und die sind total unterschiedlich
jan aber es gab halt zum beispiel also
gerade wenn es irgendwie um
unterschiedliche menschen gab dann gab's
diese vorstand die sind so wegen dem
wetter also irgendwelche länder und so
weiter ist es so warm die müssen sich
nicht anstrengen
deshalb setzt nämlich so tough wie die
tollen europäer die gegen das harte
wetter kämpfen müssen und wenn die
hierhin kommen dann können die werden
wie wir oder wenn die christen werden
dann können die werden wie wir und der
moderne rassismus verdankt fiel dem
antisemitismus der tatsächlich gesagt
werden der jude an und für sich ist so
und sogar die konvertierten sind nicht
wirklich also da gibt es so ganz
unglückliche verquickungen mit einander
also menschen essenziell irgendwie die
auf eine rolle festzuschreiben die
bleibt egal was passiert und dann haben
wir natürlich mit diesen ganzen also mit
der aufklärung mit den kolonial
bewegungen auch tatsächlich diese
vorstellung von welche
irgendwie haben eine geschichte und
welches und außerhalb der geschichte in
der regel der sagt afrika jenseits der
geschichte kennt der irgendwie sehr sehr
klar auch eine eigene rassenlehre
tatsächlich vertritt
und wir wollen ja jetzt ein tauchen
diese identitätspolitik und vielleicht
uns noch einmal wirklich ganz dingfest
zu machen es geht einerseits darum eben
minderheiten sichtbar zu machen zu
anerkennen dass die wiederum anerkannt
werden wollen und da geht es ja immer
auch um die frage der repräsentation wer
spricht eigentlich für wie ich finde ein
gutes beispiel sind der schweiz
eigentlich das frauenstimmrecht das
wurde 1971 eingeführt frauen durften
dann auch wählen gehen durften auch
abstimmen aber sie würden ganz lange
immer noch nicht in die parlamente
gewählt und die männer haben natürlich
gesagt das ist doch kein problem wir
sprechen ja auch für euch und wir gucken
ja auch dass es euch gut geht
aber die frauen haben dafür gekämpft
repräsentiert zu sein selber da wirklich
gewählt zu sein und um diesen kampf geht
es ja weiterhin welche gruppe muss
selber eigens aus person repräsentiert
werden ich finde es gerade mit dem
frauenstimmrecht ein wahlrecht eine ganz
ganz wichtige ein ganz tolles tollen
vergleich auch weil natürlich nicht jede
frau macht feministische politik aber
wenn es halt nur sehr sehr wenig frauen
in den parlamenten gibt dann ist das ein
sehr guter katalyse ist sowieso ein
indikator dafür wie irgendwie
gleichberechtigt eine gesellschaft ist
und sie würden auch fahren oder
repräsentation ist ein wichtiges element
identitäts politisch gesehen und gruppen
wirklich sehen zu können
repräsentation es ganz wichtig es gibt
ganz viele unterschiedliche formen von
repräsentation und wir gucken also
gerade zum beispiel irgendwie im film
und so dann gucken wir immer auf die
schauspieler schauspielerin aber wie ist
es hinter den kulissen wie es ist bei
den entscheidungsträgern bei den jurys
zum beispiel für irgendwie preise wie
sieht es da aus für literatur irgendwie
und da sieht man halt tatsächlich dass
die in der regel noch sehr sehr sehr
weiß und das ist ja in ordnung also
irgendwie weiße menschen zum menschen
natürlich aber wir alle gucken mit
unseren brillen auf die welt und je
weiter wir schauen des toten wie diverse
ist natürlich auch das ergebnis dessen
worüber wir reden können und das hat ja
auch viel mit erfahrungen zu tun damit
möchte ich überhaupt nicht sagen ich für
alle frauen sprechen könnte ich habe ja
nicht an
frau gefragt und ich kann ihre
einwilligung gegeben oder dass ich für
alle profis sprechen kann wer auch immer
das sein soll auch da sind die
definitionen gar nicht so eindeutig wie
ja übrigens bei frauen auch nicht aber
wenn keine die soll menschen beteiligt
sondern ist das ein sehr gutes zeichen
dafür dass man wirklich was nicht stimmt
mit repräsentation
sie haben sich gerade aus poesie
bezeichnet sind sie vielleicht kurz
übersetzten passion of koller darauf
kommen wir später auch noch ein zurück
also personen die eben nicht weiß sind
sozusagen ein sammelbegriff auch können
wir nachher noch drüber sprechen
sie haben jetzt deutlich gemacht wie
sehr das theater und der film sich
eigentlich eignet um diese frage der
repräsentation auch zu verhandeln und
tatsächlich passiert da im moment ja
auch ganz viel ein gutes beispiel ist
der aufruf herr stark 885 schauspieler
und schauspielerinnen haben sich in der
süddeutschen zeitung geoutet im letzten
frühjahr und haben quasi gesagt wir sind
lesbisch wir sind schwul wir sind trans
wir sind intersexuell und so weiter wir
sind wir und wir werden nicht gesehen
einerseits gibt es zu wenig wirklich
sichtbar machen von krones im film im
theater und andererseits werden diese
rollen wiederum dauernd von personen
gespielt sie selber nicht wir sind geht
jetzt diese idee dass sie ihre rollen
nur noch besetzt werden dürfen mit
queren schauspieler und
schauspielerinnen nicht so weit dass ich
ganz schön also ich glaube auf lange
sicht ist es natürlich nicht so dass das
unser ziel sein soll aber in der
situation der wir im moment sind es ist
wirklich also werde ich in meinem leben
schaue ich wie beim krippenspiel haben
jemand sagt du kannst dich maria spiel
marias blond bei maria im beet leben
natürlich blond
du bist milch das heißt ich habe als
kind musste ich immer black facing
machen im krippenspiel in der schule
weil ich war dann das dunkelste kind und
dann haben sie mich doch so ein bisschen
mit lockenperücke unglaublich also das
heißt wir haben eine vorstellung wer was
repräsentieren kann und wir haben die
vorstellung weiße menschen irgendwie
streiten menschen können alle
repräsentieren während irgendwie
menschen irgendwann markiert sind können
nur das spielen und irgendwie um das
aufzubrechen und zu sagen wir warten mal
wir dürfen keine wir sollen halt nur
ihre rollen spielen
die werden dann auch noch zum größten
teil von nicht kreieren menschen
gespielt da stimmt was er lasst uns
wenigstens die rollen spielen halt ist
es halt ein ganz wichtiges instrument
auch weil die art wie es gespielt wird
ja ganz häufig so travestie sind also
ein also das gibt ja auch immer mit
diesem kerne war jetzt darf sich niemand
mehr als chinese verkleiden ja genau wie
und so weiter und wo ich denke ja
natürlich irgendwie ist es ja
schrecklich wie willst du noch als
blumen oder tiere gehen aber
gleichzeitig die art wie menschen
repräsentiert wenn die inland inderinnen
dann wie aus tausend und einer nacht und
aladdin
es ist wirklich das nimmt mir manchmal
den atem
also dieses noch mal drüber nachdenken
wie repräsentiere ich etwas und aus
dieser selbstverständlichkeit
rauszukommen und es macht man eben nicht
mit ich gebe mir viel mühe das ist das
was wird aus der wirtschaft keinen
selbstverpflichtungen führen zu nichts
also müssen einbruch machen wir müssen
irgendwie sagen so halt und jetzt müssen
wir neu nachdenken was genau nimmt ihnen
den atem
also es ist schon jedes indische
klischee darin und ich bin ja mein leben
lang immer damit konfrontiert worden
also wir haben ja so wenig bilder von
indien in deutschland außer sind die
ganz weisen menschen und chance das ist
gerade die repräsentation im
karnevalskostüm das war dann wie junge
männer versucht haben mich an zu mir zu
erklären dass sie jetzt interesse an mir
haben weil irgendwie ich habe auch das
kamasutra gelesen oder also das tollste
war dass an dieser capito indische
frauen sind die schönsten frauen auf der
welt und sie sehen alle gleich aus danke
zoll mit sich bringen natürlich noch
einmal zurück zu dieser frage der
repräsentation
mir fiel in diesem kontext noch eddie
redmayne ein schauspieler der natürlich
hoch dekoriert ist er hat einen auftrag
erhalten für seine darstellung des
schwerkranken astrophysikers stephen
hawking und gleichzeitig auf der eine
oscar nomination erhalten für seine
darstellung der lili lb eine
intersexuelle malerin eine der ersten
die eine geschlechtsanpassung hat
vornehmen lassen
und er ist großartig in diesen rollen
und natürlich frage ich mich jetzt eben
hier ist weder intersex noch war er
irgendwann mit einer behinderung
montiert darf man ihn trotzdem jetzt
noch bewundern für sein spiel absolut
also ich glaube tatsächlich bei diesen
ganzen debatten und cultural preschen
sind die debatten wichtig jeder einzelne
fall ist ja falsch also irgendwie zu
sagen der darf das lächeln die darf das
nicht ist immer falsch aber überhaupt es
zu öffnen zu sagen halt könnte hier
etwas nicht stimmen das ist unglaublich
produktiv weil ganz lange war es
wirklich umgekehrt also deshalb weiß er
menschen und wie gesagt haben wir wissen
aber besser wie rassismus funktion ihr
seid zu betroffen ihr könnt ja gar nicht
reden wenn ihr haltet ihr mal den mund
ganz lange war es halt so dass es seit
heute auch wenn wir uns die ganzen
museen angucken irgendwie sie sind ja
irgendwie voll mit irgendwie raubgut
also und und das da kommt ja die debatte
um hans operation her das ist das
kulturelle aneignung und aneignung
operation war wirklich auch stelen
diebstahl irgendwie zum eigentümer zum
privateigentum machen und ganz viele von
diesen kunstmann dachten das ja auch
also irgendwie der elgin marbles in
london
irgendwie dachte lord elgin wirklich die
hören als er die aus der akropolis
mitgenommen und das ist mein ist meine
persönlichen und da musste ihm die
britische regierung die abkaufen und
jetzt haben wir diesen langen streit mit
griechenland rückgabe nicht drücken
natürlich muss nie zurückgegeben werden
und der gedanke an dem ihr könnt nicht
gut genug mit eurem eigenen kultur gut
umgehen
wir behalten das besser machen können
das besser da kommen diese debatten
herrn ist ganz schwierig wenn es dann um
so nicht materielles kultur gut geht wie
ist das mit ideen wie ist es mit
identität und da ist es nur trotzdem
drauf zu gucken wie es verhandelt wird
super wichtig und da gibt es ganz viele
beispiele wo man ganz viele diskussionen
nun diese kulturelle aneignung
vielleicht und ein paar aktuelle
beispiele zu nehmen aus der popkultur
es wird immer wieder diskutiert darf zum
beispiel in tranchen sich noch solche
zöpfe flechten und so umgehen darf katy
perry sich aus gescher verkleiden und so
auftreten oder madonna die sich schmuck
des bayerischen volkes umhängt
nordafrika und so ihre show ein
zelebriert ist das noch in ordnung oder
nicht also erstmal es kommt keine
polizei vorbei und sagt ihr durch das
nicht aber leute sagen uns gefällt das
nicht
und dann wird ja immer gesagt ja im
internet irgendwie die wollen es
verbieten
ja ja es ist tatsächlich so also ich
würde mir keine dreadlocks machen obwohl
die ältesten darstellung von dread locks
live kennen kommen also iz genau genau
meistens sind es nicht mehr nur die
geflochtenen sondern auch für diese
diese diese versetzten zöpfe die kommen
wirklich aus in dessen darstellung von
krishna aber weil es halt eine lange
geschichte gibt das irgendwie schwarze
menschen die ihre haare natürlich tragen
keine jobs bekommen haben er irgendwie
von der polizei angehalten werden
der gedanke auch wenn michelle obama
irgendwie ein afro getragen hätte wäre
barack obama niemals präsident geworden
ich glaube dass tatsächlich also man
sich diese lange leidvolle geschichte
anguckt dann muss ich sagen ist die
frage möchte ich jetzt persönlich
dreadlocks tragen oder nicht erst mal
eine geringere als als auch ein bisschen
respekt vor leuten die sagen halt
gleichzeitig natürlich gibt es ganz
viele sachen die als corporation
verhandelt werden annie sprinkle die ich
ja sehr sehr bewundere die künstlerin
annie sprinkle hat sich als kalif also
dargestellt auf einem ihrer wie seine
ihnen die stadt ihnen eine indische
göttin mit vielen armen und irgendwie
sprenkel in dem ein hatte sind an die
beratung im anderen irgendwie
verschiedene andere instrumentarien und
es war für mich so befreiend also weil
halt in dem plötzlich aus diesem bild
der irgendwie angepassten schweigenden
frau herausgenommen wurde und seine
popkultur währung hatte und plötzlich
krank war und aufregend war
und der wurde das ja auch in
anführungszeichen verboten er hat auch
niemand gesagt du musst eine strafe
zahlen über leute fanden ist nicht gut
und sie macht das nicht mal ich habe
lange mit ihm unterhalten gesagt da für
mich wäre es so wichtig und für mich war
so befreien
es gibt keine einfachen antworten darauf
dass wir darüber reden ist aber trotzdem
gut
und auch da sehen wir wieder es ist ein
so genanntes minenfeld und sie haben
jetzt glaube ich sehr schön gesagt
minenfeld heißt ja nicht dass man dinge
nicht mehr tun darf es heißt aber auch
nicht was man sich nicht kritisieren
darf und noch weniger auf kritik schon
heißt du darfst das nicht mehr tun es
ist ein verboten es gibt jetzt ein baum
über dich und ich finde da die
auseinandersetzung des philosophen kwame
anthony appiah sehr hilfreich in seinem
buch identität ein unglaublich
produktives buch wenn es um dieses thema
und er setzt sich auch ja mit
kultureller einigung auseinander und
erzählt eine schöne geschichte nämlich
die geschichte der glasperlen aus murano
glasperlen die total wichtig waren für
murano für diese insel neben venedig und
es war mit todesstrafe belegt werde ist
das rezept sozusagen sie diese glasperle
verraten hat trotzdem wurden die
glasperlen natürlich exportiert und
irgendwann waren die an der
elfenbeinküste in afrika zu finden und
wurden bei zermatt und zu neuen perlen
geformt und heute gibt es klaus berning
ghana die da ein ganz wichtiges
kulturgut sind und ob eier sagt dann wir
sehen daran kultur kann man nicht
stehlen kultur ist fluide kultur wandert
immer und natürlich übernehmen wir
dauernd kulturelle elemente und das ist
auch schön und der kultur aber und das
ist der springende punkt bei ihnen
es gibt natürlich so etwas wie
herablassen der kulturelle aneignung wo
man sich eben lustig macht über andere
kulturen oder es gibt auch kulturellen
diebstahl bei dem es einfach darum geht
einseitig zu profitieren
ein gutes beispiel ist da biopiraterie
dass wir eben welche rezepte stehen für
krems er in indigenen völkern und dann
großes geld damit machen und sie nicht
entschädigen dafür genau also es gibt
macht und innerhalb von machtstrukturen
kann es auch machtmissbrauch geben ich
würde genauso sagen kultur besteht ja
immer aus aneignung einfühlung sich das
andere hinein fühlen wenn ich nur noch
irgendwie sozusagen schreiben würde wie
ich es selber erfunden habe kann ich ja
noch mein tagebuch veröffentlicht das
wäre ja schrecklich aber das wir gerne
lesen aber aber umgekehrt ist es
tatsächlich so wäre macht es
selbstverständlich wäre sagt
selbstverständlich ist ansprechend für
und wer hat ein viel größeres eine viel
größere scheu davor und auch das ist
total spannend zu untersuchen
gehen wir noch mal zurück zum fehlen
weil die frage ist ja tatsächlich wie
gehen wir damit um also was können wir
tun um aus dieser schwierigkeit
herauszukommen
dieser ungleichen repräsentation und ein
vorschlag ist das sogenannte combined
casting und dieses rezept wurde
angewandt in der preisgekrönten netflix
serie
die roben sind opulent das setting ist
historisch england 1813 der königshof
vergnügt sich mit tratsch und klatsch
über heiratswillige junge frauen so
kitschig so historisch denkbar doch die
queen ist schwarz und der halbe hofstaat
ebenso bevölkert von dunkelhäutigen
jugend
[Musik]
wie ist das möglich im eigentlich weißen
königshaus
das zauberwort heißt farben blindes
casting man ignoriert bewusst die
hautfarbe bei der besetzung von rollen
für die deutsche schauspielerin salma
burbank die am zürcher schauspielhaus
spielt ist das höchste zeit
ich finde es sowieso mal krass und man
sieht es in filmen oder auch anderen das
so fabelwesen frau kommen auch auf der
bühne das geht alles drachen geht aber
schwarzer könig da gehen salma borbely
spielt seit jahren im deutschsprachigen
fernsehen und oft bestimmt nur ihre
hautfarbe welche rolle sie bekommt hat
sich persönlich wieso wieso sollte ich
da gar nicht kennen weil ich schwarz bin
obwohl ich seit meinem dritten
lebensjahr in deutschland lebe aus dem
rheinland komme sogar kölsch spreche ja
also sozusagen rheinische mädchen bin
durch sich aber wenn ich gedreht habe
immer nur prostituierte dienstmädchen
sklaven oder rechts spielen oder am oder
gar kein deutscher gebrochenes deutsch
oder meisten afrikanisch reden mit
meinem kollegen und schwarzen ist mal so
wir sind afrikanische trotz klischees
das bewusstsein people of kohlezug
rasten ist gestiegen auch wenn
hauptrollen rar sind und auf die schweiz
bezogen kann man sich ein heidi
vorstellen dunkelhäutig
[Musik]
oder einen wilhelm tell all zu
konzeptionell der tag und sondern
wirklich gut und qualität hat dann kann
ich mir sogar vorstellen dass das
publikum findet wie wilhelm tell und
fülle das habe ich schon hundertmal
gesehen und normalen telefonen tolles
lang aber wenn das so ist wird das
frische wind ich habe das schon
vorstellen
das könnte in frischer wind sein mal ein
dunkelhäutiges heidi was ist jetzt aber
auch nicht wirklich das ziel der
repräsentation oder ein bisschen
frischen wind zu machen wenn ich kann
hier nur als japanisch also als manga
das ist als kind bewundert also habe ich
natürlich sofort genommen
ich finde dieses kaplan kampf den super
war ich antworten so körperlich
erleichtern also ist zu sehen war
wirklich nur so weil wir kennen das ja
bei diesen ganzen kostümfilm die sind ja
nie historisch korrekt also deshalb jane
austen wird ja immer alles und so vier
jahre neu gedreht man kann es immer
datieren man weiß aus den siebzigern aus
den 80ern aus den neunzigern weil man
sieht ja es ist unser blick auf die
geschichte von shakespeare company ist
immer irgendwie das ist immer kann er
blind casting also weil die die sind ja
ganz anders ein weg votiert natürlich
und es fällt niemandem auf als wir gehen
ins theater und finden es großartig sie
ist interessant weil sie sagen na ja es
ist ja immer irgendwie geschlecht
geschichtsklitterung und es ist nie
wirklich historisch getreue aber
trotzdem hat man genau diesen vorwurf
britta 10 gemacht nur gesagt das ist
eben viel zu viel verdrehungen der
geschichte zum beispiel weil das england
des regions england im 19 jahrhundert
natürlich extrem rassistisch war und es
war vollkommen undenkbar dass simon am
hofe eine person people of colour
geheiratet hätte und der vorfahrt an
dass man gesagt hat schon okay wenn die
person auf koloss mitspielen aber bitte
gebt ihnen die rollen die sie auch
historisch gehabt hätten und zeigt auf
was für ein rassismus ist damals gegeben
hat na ja gut das ist ja immer die frage
was erwarten will jetzt von also das ist
ja etwas das gucke ich wegen den den sie
in erotischen szenen also ich gucke es
jetzt nicht weil ich
unendlich viel über rassismus erfahren
möchte das erwarte ich dann von anderen
film aber es ist ja auch ganz so stimmt
es nicht also es gab ja immer diese
ausnahmen auch da die dann irgendwie
adoptiert wurden oder die aufgewachsen
sind und ich weiß wie darum wie wichtig
ist für irgendwie leid wir uns dass die
ja so im im kollektiven gedächtnis nicht
vorkommen diese figuren auch zu finden
die auch wiederzufinden für deutschland
war es für mich zum beispiel seehofer
nur die kaiserin und eine deutsche
kaiserin mit meiner hautfarbe
byzantinische prinzessin im jahr 1000
also um die jahrtausendwende war sie
kaiserin von deutschland hat den
deutschen gabel mitgebracht und diese
gehen dass hände hat schon absehen
beigebracht im moment total wichtig dies
in meiner nachbarstadt in köln begraben
in st pantaleon in köln haben wir da
immer mit der schule irgendwie ausflüge
gemacht nein natürlich nicht ich habe
nichts von der erfahren wir wussten es
nicht also diese menschen wenn natürlich
auch im kollektiven gedächtnis heraus
redigiert und es ist ja nicht nur mich
dass wir jetzt repräsentieren sollen
dass wir auch unsere geschichte
repräsentieren dass der gedanke von wir
waren eine weiße narzissen europäer sind
und wie nordafrikaner also genetischen
und könnte man böse sagen die kinder
müssen in der schule ja trotzdem lernen
das ist extremen rassismus gab dass es
diese kolonialzeit gab und dass das
alles wirkt bis heute also sehen wir
beispielsweise dem ganzen die ganze
diskussion über die heirat von von harry
und und merken also wo man den eindruck
gehabt natürlich wirkt da ganz viel
rassismus weiter nach und wenn man sich
das vor augen führt versteht man doch
vielleicht auch dass man sagt zeigt
bitte historische serien so wie es
wirklich war
das ist die frage irgendwie ist es die
aufgabe von serien oder das ist die
aufgabe von schule weil ich glaube
tatsächlich ein antirassistisches wissen
an schulen und universitäten zu
unterrichten wäre halt wahnsinnig
wichtig sind ja auch so die forderung
des europarates irgendwie dass wir
implementieren müssen deutschland hat
überhaupt gerade erst in der verfassung
geändert dass wir halt in unserer
erinnerungskultur halt eben nicht nur
den holocaust der ganz ganz wichtig ist
in der kultur sondern halt auch
irgendwie wie ist es mit irgendwie weiß
also nie wie es da irgendwie
diskriminierung wie funktioniert das wir
müssen wir um diese menschen gemeinsam
trauern also geht ja auch darum dass
menschen wie wir wir trauern um unsere
opfer
das ist ein politisches anliegen und ich
würde gerne tatsächlich mit ihm
zurückkommen auch zur identitätspolitik
also zu diesen ganzen politischen
anliegen man aber mit den eindruck es
werden immer mehr und immer noch
kleinere gruppen die anerkennung und
partizipation verlangen denken wir an
ein kürzel die lgbt also die lesben die
schwulen die trans menschen die
bisexuellen die erweitert wurden um die
buchstaben q also queer intersex und
sexuell und viele sagen da komme ich
überhaupt nicht mehr mit was sollen wir
denn jetzt machen noch ein ganzes
alphabet hinten dranhängen sollten wir
uns nicht wieder auf ein wir besinnen
staatliches klein klein
ich glaube beides ist richtig und für
beides spricht ganz viel weil wir
brauchen eine eine rhetorik der
gemeinsamkeit eine ganz ganz wichtige
rhetorik der gemeinsamkeit
gesamtgesellschaftlich übrigens nicht
nur die denn stets wichtig das bräuchte
auch im parlament geht um dieser
gespräche gleichzeitig müssen wir
natürlich auch spezifische irgendwie
diskriminierungen verweisen also ich bin
in deutschland noch nie diskriminiert
worden wegen irgendwie indisch sein das
sind alles super in deutschland nun die
inder sind die weisen menschen toll ich
bin als nicht weise diskriminiert von
als leute dachten ich bin muslim frauen
gleich muslime
das heißt natürlich gibt es
unterschiedliche formen von
diskriminierung wie ist es im
schulsystem wer braucht was im
schulsystem
und da ist es halt ein problem wenn wir
einfach nur sagen okay wer wird im
schulsystem diskriminiert aber irgendwie
an
im moment sind es hauptsächlich jungs
das stimmt als ganz lange wand
hauptsächlich mädchen vans und jungen
die bildungsverlierer
da muss man genau drauf gucken ganz
merken es sind die migrantische
markierten jungs die massive
bildungsverlierer im bildungssystem sind
das heißt da müssen wir gegensteuern das
heißt wir brauchen die richtige analyse
und jörg scheller sagt es so schön wenn
wir eine politik der identifikation
machen brachte gleichzeitig aber eine
politik der der vision also irgendwie
der imagination freunde gemeinsam hin
und dass wir so ein bisschen immer in
eine richtung tendieren aber beides
gehört zusammen also wenn wir nicht auf
das verweisen was die geschichte ist
irgendwie dann neigen wir dazu zu sagen
wieso und wie alles alles ist dasselbe
und das kennen wir zum beispiel aus der
frauenbewegung also aus dem kampf gegen
den paragraf 218 dass frank nur weil das
recht auf abtreibung haben das dann
irgendwie frauen behinderungen gesagt
haben
wenn dazu gezwungen abzutragen wir
werden zwangssterilisiert auch das muss
gesehen werden und da war es ganz
wichtig das zu benennen
also quasi eine andere gruppe die noch
mal ein anderes anliegen einbringt und
anerkennung wünscht als diese gruppe
genau genau um halt auch wirklich für
alle eine gerechte politik zu machen
ich kam sehen und ich glaube viele
können sehen wie wichtig solche anliegen
sind aber es gibt auch die gegenbewegung
caroline fuhr ist zum beispiel eine
französische intellektuelle selber
lesbisch selber feministisch hat lange
für charlie hebdo geschrieben eine frau
die immer wieder angefeindet wurde für
ihr links sein die hat ein buch
geschrieben mit dem titel generation
beleidigt und sagt es gehe hier
mittlerweile um einen sogenannten
identitäten antirassismus und sie sagt
es geht alles viel zu weit es geht nicht
mehr um einen universalismus dass wir
versuchen gemeinsam für menschenrechte
und antidiskriminierung einzustehen
sondern es gibt nur noch um dieses kein
klein nur noch um sprache es geht nur
noch um ansprüche von einzelnen gruppen
und es klappt nicht mehr dass wir diese
vision von der jörg scheller spricht
noch im blick haben
also manchmal ist das gefühl dass das
eigentlich eine kritik am internet also
so funktioniert das internet inhalt geht
ja immer auf die sozusagen lautesten
irgendwie und identität irgendwie es
halt sehr einfach zu verstehen in
soundsoviel zeichen und das stimmt also
nur wie es im internet handelt wird da
sträuben sich mir auch manchmal die
haare wenn man sich dann aber mal
genauer anguckt wofür stehen die leute
dann ist es ja viel viel differenzierter
ich finde eine interne kritik richtig
also müssen immer aufpassen dass
identitätspolitik nicht identitaire wird
aber zu sagen ach dann kann man es
direkt alles in die tonne schmeißen
brauchen wir nicht mehr weil wir uns die
schlechtesten beispiele raus becken das
kann ich bei alle machen dann kann ich
komplette philosophie in die tonne
schmerz kann sein dass es durch brauchen
wir nicht mehr sitzen wäre schrecklich
natürlich also ist es also hannah arendt
die ich sehr liebe unglaublich
schrecklich rassistische dinge hat sie
geschrieben
trotzdem ist sie eine so wichtige auch
für mein denken so wichtige philosophen
und ich finde man muss halt sehen ich
kritisiere das aber ich würde nicht
damit ist die ganze sache erledigt eine
kritik die auch immer wieder kommt ist
das zuviel fokus auf sprache liegt das
ist auch eine kritik die sahra
wagenknecht in ihrem neuen buch die
selbstgerechten
bringt und sagt wir unterhalten uns
stundenlang seiten lang freute lang über
gender sternchen und co statt über die
wirklich die wichtigen dinge zu sprechen
nämlich wirklich vorhandene
diskriminierung wie sie das sagt nämlich
niedriglohnbereich personen die keine
papiere haben migrantinnen und migranten
die keine anerkennung sind und so weiter
was entgegnen sie ihr warum ist sprache
so wichtig also ich glaube es ist beides
also ich habe mir ein buch über die
vulva geschrieben und jeweils mir
wichtig war im film ist das genital
benennen wir sagen wagen irgendwie wenn
wir die vulva meinen wenn die welt
vagina ist ja rein medizinisch ist das
hier wirklich dieser schleimhaut
schlauch und irgendwie die vulva ist das
sichtbare genital und wenn wir es nicht
benennen können dann kann über ganz
viele dinge nicht sprechen sein kann
über schmerzen nicht sprechen kann nur
lust nicht sprechen dann haben wir ein
riesiges problem
das ist die eine sache ich kann relativ
wenig leute die nur sprach politik
machen nebenbei aber wo wagenknecht
recht hat ist es ist total leicht über
sprache zu reden das heißt die medien
wenn ich über sprache sein sie hat das
ist ja spannend machte es mal wenn ich
über niedriglohnsektor sprechen möchte
wenn ich über flucht sprechen möchte man
sagen das ist so kompliziert mach mal
lieber was über gender sternchen und das
ist ja ein riesiges problem also das ja
dass wir in den medien was in den medien
repräsentiert wird ist ja nicht dass das
politisch gemacht wird und eine andere
frage die auch immer wieder aufkommt ist
wer darf eigentlich worüber sprechen
wenn wir über sprache sprechen also so
sprechverbote die ausgesprochen werden
dass man sagt ein weißer kann sich nicht
zu rassismus äußern beispielsweise ich
schon am an gott ist da kritisch wenn es
um solche sprechverbote geht ganz kurz
zu dieser auf twitter sehr beliebte
spruch einfach mal die klappe halten
gerne gerichtet an alte weiße
heterosexuelle cis männer der meint er
genau dieses von bestimmten gruppen ist
nicht zu erwarten dass das zur debatte
noch eine neue erkenntnis beizusteuern
ist deswegen sollen die erst mal die
klappe halten und das ist was mir nicht
gefällt diese vorstellung dass es
sinnvoll sein könnte quasi so ein
schematisches muster vor jede debatte zu
setzen zu sagen von wem ein einspruch zu
hören ist und von denen nicht was sagen
sie dazu
dem kann ich natürlich nur zustimmen es
ist natürlich ganz schrecklich zu sagen
du musst die klappe
halten die kritik bezieht sich in erster
linie darauf das klassischerweise an je
wenn es um das thema rassismus geht dann
werden die experten eingeladen oder
überhaupt noch weiß also im wdr hatten
wird es in der letzten instanz das sind
51 menschen eingeladen nicht-experten
man ihn nicht mit dem thema zu tun
hatten die dann abstimmen sollten was
ist rassistisch und was nicht und
einfach sich in wie total wirklich
entblödet haben in dem mwc dass man
gemerkt hat dass sind prominente die
haben keine ahnung von dem thema ich
würde ja auch nicht irgendwie sagt ach
lasst mich mal über fußball reden
irgendwie ich kann auch sagen ob die
schön rasiert sind an den beinen also
ich habe keine ahnung von fußball
ich habe das ja auch nicht anmaßen und
ich kenne das ganz ganz häufig dass es
einen bestimmten typus gibt er meint er
kann zu allem reden und da hab ich
manchmal dass dringend bedürfen hörte
auch mal zu also ich glaube überhaupt
nicht es geht um klappe halten es geht
auch darum das ist eine fähigkeit
zuhören zu lernen eine feld hat man sich
einfühlen zu lernen erst mal auch einen
wissen über ein thema zu haben
gleichzeitig werden nur noch irgendwie
betroffene über ein thema das wäre
schrecklich will eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche debatte führen
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass
natürliche weise menschen ebenfalls über
rassismus reden aber nicht in exklusion
von anlagen und dagegen wendet sich dass
er eigentlich und dieses zu hören hat ja
auch damit zu tun dass geben nicht
einfach zuschreibungen machen sondern
ich weiß noch so schön kübra gümüsay ja
auch mal hier war die haben gesagt ich
bin eine bezeichnete hier dauernd seien
dauernd zuschreibung gemacht sie haben
das ja auch gesagt werden auch muslime
bezeichnet zum beispiel aber dann heißt
das ja auch dass sie uns über unsere
identitäten rechenschaft ablegen müssen
und überlegen wer sind wir ja eigentlich
und ich würde sie gerne mal fragen wer
sind denn sie eigentlich total toll weit
ist ist ja wirklich die frage mit der
ich mein leben lang immer am häufigsten
konfrontiert wurden also wo kommst du
her irgendwie und egal was ich darauf
gesagt habe die leute mögen sie ist die
falsche antwort
also würde ich gesagt ich komme aus
düsseldorf will designlinie bekommst du
wirklich bissig den bürgern gesagt habe
mein vater kommt aus indien dann waren
die glücklich es war die richtige
antwort hängt sogar wenn ich ihn sagt
man mutter kommt aus polen niveau kommen
so wirklich eigentlich war es die frage
warum bist du braun und da muss ich
sagen ganz im ernst
ich kann interesse nachvollziehen aber
nur wenn es mir selber die möglichkeit
lässt so sagen ich möchte darauf
antworten ich möchte darauf nicht
antworten
ich möchte auch meine meine
lebensgeschichte öffnen also wir sind ja
irgendwie komplexe dinge die vielleicht
dazu führen und vielleicht möchte ich
mich jetzt gar nicht so weit in team
irgendwie mit jemandem vorsicht nahm
einen namen also ganz heutig wirklich
bevor die gefragt habe sag wie hast du
kommst du her aber interessant ist ja
trotzdem haben jetzt gesagt sie möchten
gerne entscheiden worüber sie sprechen
möchten oder nicht das heißt sie möchten
auch gewisse fragen nicht gestellt hat
das kann ich sehr gut verstehen
trotzdem ist die identitätsfragen frage
für bestimmte menschen würde ich jetzt
mal sagen brisanter oder akuter und das
beschreiben sie eben in ihrem roman
identität so wunderbar da geht es um
eine figur die eigentlich jetzt von der
herkunft her sage ich jetzt mal
identisch ist mit ihnen also auch diese
figur hat eine polnische mutter und
einen indischen vater auch diese person
studiert in düsseldorf auf diese person
studiert post kolonie studies sie haben
ähnliche studien auch gemacht also es
gibt viele parallelen zwischen diesen
beiden figuren und für diese frau hier
ist es ganz wichtig die identitätsfrage
für sich stellen zu können was sie sich
immer schon damit konfrontiert sieht und
ich habe mich dann gefragt ich habe mir
diese frage nie gestellt natürlich frage
ich mich was ist mir wichtig im leben
wer bin ich im sinne von was passt zu
mir
was möchte ich im leben sein wofür
möchte ich gerade stehen
aber ansonsten stellt sich mir die frage
nicht und natürlich ist wahrscheinlich
dass ein zeichen dafür dass ich enorm
privilegiert bin an dem punkt ja also
wir sind ja alle vier punkt privilegiert
einander nicht erfüllt auch im fernsehen
sprechen zu können ist ja eine massive
privilegierung das muss man ja auch
ehrlich sagen für nivea ist es halt das
ist ja die figuren die die hauptfigur
ist es so unglaublich wichtig weil ihr
halt immer nur gesagt wurde wo sie nicht
hingehört na also sie in deutschland
halt irgendwie also wie gesagt ich bin
in deutschland geboren als ich geboren
wurde ich es natürlich ausländerin das
einfach der falsche begriff ist ich hab
noch nie lange in einem anderen land
gelebt ich bin keine ausländerin und
dass sie halten noch ganz kurz
unterbrechen ja das ist so schön zu
sagen an einer stelle auch ausländerin
wurden sie genannt dann gastarbeiterkind
ja komisch ist bald gäste
eigentlich ein viel geld man nicht
einmal dass sie arbeiten und dann gab es
auch noch personen mit
migrationshintergrund was wir sie ja
auch nicht passt na ja also es ist fast
schon aber irgendwie mein mann ist
engländer der es während seiner
lebenszeit nach deutschland komme ich
bin in deutschland geboren worden den
fragt niemand nach seinem
migrationshintergrund weil er weiß ist
also außer entgeht dass sie dann
irgendwie alle sofort mit dem englisch
reden weil englische die tollste sprache
der welt ist egal wie schlecht sie
englisch sprechen können
er spricht ja wirklich sehr sehr gut
deutsch aber wir sprechen alle irgendwie
gutes englisch mit ihm und es ist wie so
ein sich verneigen vor dieser englischen
identität was mir manchmal fast
unangenehm genau und für nivea ist es
halt so dass sie niemals einfach
irgendwo passend war interessanterweise
irgendwie bis sie dann nach birmingham
fährt irgendwie im ihre cousine zu
besuchen uns zum ersten mal so wie sie
aussieht nicht und ich aus dem bild
heraus fällt dann sagt er da aber
irgendjemand du bist eine kokosnuss also
bis außen braun und innen war es aber
egal
auch da darf sie nicht wirklich dazu
gehören und sie will sie ihn weiß weiß
ich zu sehr identifiziert mit sagen wir
mal nur weil es einfach kinder sind weil
es irgendwie so hübsch ist weil sie die
damit kriegen können sie hat eine weiße
mutter das ist irgendwie tatsächlich
richtig aber was ist denn ihnen nicht
weiß also was ist denn echt indisch und
das auch in indien zum beispiel muss
jedes klischee an der inneren seien also
weil sie muss ja beweisen dass sie
indisch genug ist und sie darf es nicht
brechen und ich und das ist ja dieses
irgendwie ich bin frau als ich bin als
und wie mädchen irgendwie identifiziert
worden bei der geburt das heißt 80 rosen
anziehen natürlich darf mir die haare
kurz schneiden usw
wenn ich aber eine transall wäre werden
ist ein riesiges problem war er müsste
ich ja beweisen dass ich wirklich es
ernst genug meine und so geht es ihr
halt mit indien
denkt ihr dass sie halt immer auf dem
prüfstand steht so geht es ihr mit polen
so geht er mit deutschland- und sie
möchte einmal dieses
kirchenzugehörigkeit haben und ich
glaube gewitter hat gesagt was brauchen
kinder irgendwie wurzeln und flügel da
gibt es eine hübsche post katar gibt es
im hören klappt hier drauf anders sobald
man diese wurzeln hat und das ist ja
auch der weg von editha in dem roman
dann kann man es auch hinter sich lassen
am ende des romans ist sie zum beispiel
auch in der lage deutschland zu
verlassen sie überlegt sie am ende froh
wenn's geht sie nach england wird sie in
oxford studieren wenn ich alles hätte
sie vorher nicht gekannt weil sie halt
noch so irgendwie ungebundenen darin
waren an dem punkt wo sie sich gebunden
genug fühlt kann sie auch sagen okay und
dann ist es und dann wird es auch
weniger wichtig wenn es nicht mehr in
frage gestellt wird und dann kann es
auch mal wieder wichtiger werden und
weniger wichtig werden
seit wann sie sich denn bewusst dass
sich diese fragen überhaupt stellen also
vielleicht noch einfache gefragt zeit
von 70 ihrer hautfarbe bewusst
das sind ganz spannende fragen will ich
was ist war immer ein thema also ich
kann mich noch am kindergarten erinnern
dieses alte ist ein kindergarten sind so
viele
damit hat man dann irgendwie am farbige
kinder gesagt wenn ich es ist ja auch
ein schreckliches wort
irgendwann wirst du da wirst du dich
irgendwie zugehörig fühlen und dann
eigentlich also es war immer immer immer
ein thema es wurde immer darüber
gesprochen ich kann mich an zeiten
erinnern lange bevor ich in der pubertät
war haben denn so eltern von freunden
freundin gesagt ja ja die südländischen
frauen irgendwie die werden ja früher
reif und die verblühen dann auch früher
ja lange bevor ich auch nur bevor es um
ein thema das war immer thema
gleichzeitig und das ist völlig parallel
hatte ich kein bewusstsein dafür dass
heißt ich habe in den spiegel geschaut
und habe nicht gesehen dass sich braun
mein sohn ich habe gedacht ich bin weiß
und sehr komisch aus
also es ist wirklich dieses weil dir
keine begriffe der vertrag eine sprache
darf hat mir kein bewusstsein dafür in
deutschland hat man ja noch gesagt es
gibt ja keine menschenrassen das haben
die nazis kann man also kann es kein
rassismus geben thema beende und ich
weiß als als ich angefangen habe zu
studieren und ich habe vieles unter
philosophie und irgendwie philosophie
war ganz ganz schwierig da merkt man
dann ganz schnell dass man nicht zu den
objekten gehört aber ich habe dann ein
lustig studiert und darin ganz viele
dieser autoren an turin gelesen die halt
auch mit eine wichtige rolle in dem buch
spielen also erzählt hab ich da gelesen
hat jetzt gerade die sp war und so
weiter und hatte da zum ersten mal eine
eine sprache für das was ich erlebt habe
die an ganz dem punkt noch nicht gepasst
hat also weil wir viel afrikanistik
beraten und entscheiden da aber mehr von
dem wieder gespielte für gefunden habe
als in allen deutschen
auseinandersetzung
im kern dieser ganzen fragen steht ja
das haben sie ganz am anfang schon mal
gesagt das was man essential ismus nennt
also diese frage inwiefern schließen die
eigentlich können wir schließen sollen
wir schließen müssen wir schließen von
äußerlichkeiten auf ähnlichkeiten und
erstmal würde man eher sagen nie das ist
keine gute idee
niemand ist so weil er oder sie so
aussieht und trotzdem gibt es dauernd
eben dieses bemühen auch wieder in der
identitätspolitik sich abzugrenzen zb
eben zu sagen wenn du so und so aussieht
dann erlebst du einfach gewisse dinge
die andere eben nicht erleben und die
nicht begreifen verstehen nachvollziehen
kannst wenn du zum beispiel nicht
schwarz bist das finde ich immer ganz
schwierig wer schwarz kann ich nicht
sagen aber irgendwie ich bin es gibt
natürlich ganz viele unterschiedliche
erfahrungen also auch und wir nicht alle
profis machen dieselben erfahrungen
natürlich nicht ich weiß und wie man man
man tatsächlich kennen zu lernen zwar zu
entlasten für mich weil er dieses gefühl
von zwischen den stühlen sitzen
ebenfalls weiß aber halt in deutschland
zu sein eben nicht wirklich deutschland
zu sein und dass das war so schön das zu
teilen
ich kenne das auch von frauengruppen
männer sind ganz anders als wir es aber
falsch natürlich für männer nicht andere
wesen es ist dieselbe spezies und
vierteilen phy phy phy phy phy viel mehr
als jede einzelne frau mit jeder
einzelnen anderen frau die beiden
gruppen aller männern aller frauen also
ich finde es falsch gleichzeitig ist
manchmal dieses gefühl von wir ziehen
uns zusammen zurück und fühlen uns
gemeinsam so schön weil wir das in der
gesellschaft zu erhalten haben und ich
kenne das eine freundin von mir hat mir
mal gesagt ja aber es hat das auch
manchmal sie geht auf die straße und
fühlt sich gar nicht mehr zu hause in
ihrem eigenen land hat das gefühl und
wie sie ist der fremdkörper und das
bezog sich auf migration ich denke aha
das habe ich aber mein leben lang gehabt
und irgendwie man kann damit gut leben
das ist gar nicht schlimm es ist auch
gar nicht es den ganzen tag über
schmerzhaft und schrecklich ist und
manchmal ist das halt hübsch das st
betoniert und es ist immer ein in eine
lange lüge aber manchmal ist das eine
eine kuschelige schöne wir tun jetzt so
als würden wir uns nur auf unsere
gemeinsamkeiten sind wenn man nur
zusammen und kann sagen wir machen und
wir machen niemals dieselben erfahrungen
aber das ist es andere menschen sind ein
paar tisch und sie können sicher waren
ich glaube also auch gerade was
rassismus angeht ich finde es ganz ganz
schwierig weil haut ist wirklich ein
konstrukt deshalb in deutschland ist
schrecklicher weise gelernt irgendwie
also man konnte irgendwie bei juden und
jüdinnen sagen sie das ist eine andere
rasse also und und wie die sind ja in
einer form irgendwie ratifiziert worden
natürlich kann weiß rassismus erleben
absolut also das ist einfach nicht so
100 dass es nur spezifische menschen
können aber es ist immer auf die
kontexte bezogen
das passieren jetzt haben sie gesagt
rasse ist ein konstrukt und das ist die
zentrale aussage auch eben in diesem
buch vielleicht müssen wir ganz bisschen
handlung noch nachliefern weil ich
möchte gerne jetzt über die pointe
dieses buches auch sprechen es geht
darin eben um diese nie wie die tat die
hauptfigur und die studiert bei einer
sarah zloty das ist eine professorin für
prost kolonien start ist auch in
düsseldorf eine koryphäe auf ihrem
gebiet die hat die standardwerke zum
thema geschrieben
die frau ist auch eine person auf cola
die trägt eine ducati genau wie sich ihr
kleid genau wie sie er hat lange
schwarze haare und irgendwann an einem
bestimmten punkt wird hat klar dass
diese frau eigentlich platz racing
betrieben hat dass sie weiß es dass die
sarah wäre heisst dass sie zwei weiße
blonde elternteile hat und dass das
alles also fake war
und der roman rollt dann diese
geschichte auf und dreht immer wieder
von neuem diese frage äußerst klug und
auch lehrreich und amüsant zugleich
diese frage weiter darf man denn zum
beispiel sagen ich bin trans race also
wenn rossi ein konstrukt ist kann ich da
nicht auch sagen ich bin zwar weiß aber
ich bin in einem weißen körper geboren
habe aber eine schwarze identität wie
genau das ist die frage die gestellt
wird die er in dem buch ambivalent
gelassen wird also das ist ja wirklich
irgendwie mit absicht ambivalent
gestaltet war ganz vieles von dem was
sie macht ist halt wichtig und richtig
und unglaublich notwendig gleichzeitig
basiert ja eher gesamtinstallation auf
einer lüge und das nie wie die taz
gesagt aber warum warum hast du mich
angelogen also nicht mal was die welt an
lunge seien mich persönlich
warum hat mir eine weiße frau erklärt
was rassismus ist du hast mein
rollenmodell ich habe meine identität
auf die aufgebaut ist und wie menschen
irgendwie fertig ist selbstbewusst
irgendwie süß ein medienstar und nie
wieder dieses auch so können braune
menschen sein und nicht nur so wie ich
bin und das war für sie ganz ganz
wichtig ich glaube das problem ist
einfach wenn es im bildungssystem
vielmehr people of colour geben dass
mehr rollenmodelle geben würde dann wäre
der betrug auch nicht so groß aber weil
sie sozusagen eine der ganz wenigen war
es halt so viel wunsch auf ihr soviel
begehren auf ihr und dadurch liegt ist
umso schwerer
gleichzeitig ist es bei razer so also im
gegensatz zu gender gender wird ja in
jeder generation neu verhandeln hat also
eine bloß weil ich eine frau bin kann
mein kind irgendwie ein junge sein also
alle meine mutter frauen sind kann ich
trotzdem ein männliches kind bekommen
der gedanke bei race ist ja das ist
trans generativ vererbt wird
und da bricht es natürlich damit
irgendwie zu sagen ja ich fühle mich
jetzt aber anders wenn die welt eine
andere wäre wenn es eine welt ohne
rassismus gäbe wenn es eine welt wo auch
die wunden geheilt und weil es ist ja
die andere sache
das eine sind die facto benachteilung
das andere sind aber die psychischen
wunden psychischen benachteilige wir
haben die dazu führen dass ist in der
welt neue benachteilung gibt auch wenn
die voraussetzungen vielleicht die
gleichen denn was ihr noch gar nicht
sind dann wäre wahrscheinlich so ein
irgendwie gender passing wie das
wasserstoff macht völlig in ordnung
wahrscheinlich bräuchten uns noch nicht
mit wahrscheinlich wäre es dann auch
nicht mehr interessant
das gab es ja auch schon ganz lange es
gibt ganz viele geschichten vorbilder wo
es eine notwendigkeit war nämlich dass
dunkelhäutige menschen versucht haben
sich weiter zu machen um meine chance zu
kriegen das heißt man versteht komplett
dass aus diesem impuls heraus teilhaben
zu dürfen der versuch im raum stand sich
stärker weiß zu machen
sie macht ja das umgekehrte und das ist
das was eben die irritierend ist und was
mich auch warum interessiert es gibt ja
viele auch doch vorbilder jetzt auch für
diesen roman
us amerikanische professorin auch
bürgerrechtsaktivisten die 2015 als weiß
geoutet wurde die eben auch sich aus
afro amerikanerin ausgegeben hat ihren
job verloren hat und so weiter
und das interessante für mich aus wie so
oft auch ist dass diese dieser von roger
dorny saal wurde in unzähligen paper
auch dann verhandelt es gibt die
feministische zeitschrift hype assia die
hat einen unglaublichen streit dann auch
los getreten weil daran paper
veröffentlicht wurde
was gesagt habe dass es in ordnung wenn
ist transgender gibt dann muss es auch
trance race geben können weil sowohl
kinder wie race sind soziale konstrukte
wenn wir das eine zu unserer eigenen
identität machen können dann auch das
andere und darauf gab es ein riesen
shitstorm was ist wirklich der kern
dieses streites warum ist das so ein
noch einmal stärkeres minenfeld ich
glaube es gibt ganz ganz ganz viele
gründe dafür wir alle kann ja verstehen
warum menschen versuchen weist zu sein
und weil irgendwie also als etavis es
braucht um überleben zu können wichtig
wenn es in die andere richtung geht bei
uns gab es auch übrigens immer sind ja
nicht nur wir haben das für das fängt
jetzt erst an es gab immer die anderen
fälle auch weil menschen heiraten
wollten und so weiter dann wurde es
entweder wirklich verdrängt das gibt es
gar nicht weil irgendwie genauso ist es
ja auch irgendwie sozusagen menschen die
als frauen wahrgenommen werden und wie
sagen ich bin aber ein man das kann kann
man verstehen in die andere richtung
wird es ja ganz heiß umstritten
also du musst es beim hierarchisch
höhergestellte wollen und wenn die
andere richtung geht und stellt sie ganz
sicher nie infrage in loser form
es hat auch viel damit zu tun weil es
ein so riesiger kampf war transgender
irgendwie ernst zu nehmen wahrzunehmen
das ist tatsächlich die befürchtung und
auch die begründete befürchtung gibt
wären wir jetzt über transfers reden
dann bringen wir werden also die spinnen
der und irgendwie dass wir dann
sozusagen errungenschaften verlieren das
ist ein gewisser form und unsolidarische
form ich glaube auf lange sicht war es
wirklich so viel konstruiert als gender
also nun auch gender ist zu einem ganz
großen teil konstruiert aber race ist
wirklich da gibt es keine biologische
grundlage für überhaupt keine mehr
das ist in irgendeiner form wird es die
möglichen sein aber wie es im moment ist
und gerade in amerika ist es halt so
hahn machen nicht was müssen sie kurz
erklären warum das so stark sozial
konstruiert ist und das sagt er zb eben
auch quam em up a ja ganz starker es ist
ein konstrukt jetzt haben sie gesagt ich
ess kimo menschenrassen also es ist also
bei tieren haben wir ja wirklich
irgendwie tiere gezüchtet und irgendwie
um ein sehr einheitlichen genpool zu
bekommen das ist ja bei menschen
wirklich anders und je menschenrassen
sind erfunden worden nach entweder
merken welche kategorien wer in welche
kategorie hinein gehört dass man es dann
an nasen festmacht und die das ist ja
auch ganz interessant irgendwie ist die
jüdische nase und die römische nase
komplett dieselben aber so sind in
diesen als auch wirklich in diesen
rassen irgendwie karten die man sich
angucken kann über die eine ist die gut
und die andere ist die böse also es ist
wirklich so an den haaren herbeigezogen
und die debatten als auch die
medizinischen debatten ganz lange wo der
wirklich noch gesagt ja aber ist rassen
gibt es ja schon es gibt wirklich keine
menschenrassen aber es gibt rassismus
und race als soziologisches konstrukt
darauf müssen wir verweisen können
deshalb ist mir antwort deshalb sage ich
auch race und nicht rasse weil in dem
englischen wort race ist das
soziologische konstrukt enthalten in dem
deutschen wort rasse ist halt wirklich
anbieters ist ein biologisches konstrukt
und dass das ist überholt also da wird
auch jeder sage klar was und um
vielleicht wirklich transparent zu sein
für alle und das noch besser zu
verstehen frage ich trotzdem noch mal
nach was haben denn hautfarbe und race
miteinander zu tun weil viele die jetzt
gleich zu schauen würden sagen ich
verstehe schon dass man zb
verunglimpfung von bestimmten menschen
dass man gesagt hat der sie zu und so
aus und ist deswegen so und so dass das
nicht in ordnung ist aber es ist doch so
wenn zwei dunkelhäutige menschen ein
kind bekommen ist das kind auch
dunkelhäutig was ist daran bitteschön
konstruiert also erstmal irgendwie geld
ja als braun ich habe eine freundin aus
süddeutschland die hat dieselbe
hautfarbe wie ich irgendwie die gilt als
marie fall so auch da funktioniert das
schon nicht mit den charts die andere
sache ist die engländer zum beispiel die
haben ja immer ganz lange schatten an
gehabt irgendwie also diesen diesen
englischen ureinwohner wurde gesagt
haben so der war eine echte englisch
ureinwohner
irgendwann haben jetzt genetisch
rausgefunden verdammt er war schwarz
also wir wissen haut schabbat ganze
tatsächlich sonne
und irgendwie wenn wir lange genug
irgendwo leben wo es weniger sonne getan
wird weniger melanin in der haut so das
heißt irgendwie egal irgendwie auch alle
meine vorfahren aus wo auch immer
herkommen wenn ich ihm genügend
generationen hier lebe werden meine
kinder irgendwann hellhäutig sein
das ist so die frage ist ja auch warum
tut sarahs war die so etwas in diesem
buch und ein ein vorwurf der gemacht hat
ist genau diese coaches appropriation
also diese kulturelle anleitung über die
wir schon gesprochen haben sie sagt aber
auch das finde ich wahnsinnig
interessant ich habe mich für mein weiß
sein zu dermaßen geschämt
das war für mich ein problem und es
steht auch in diesem buch weiß sein ist
einfach nicht cool und tatsächlich hat
man mama das gefühl
mittlerweile ist die auch sie also per
software zu sein fast schon zu einer
währung geworden in der popkultur als
launische hin also in der popkultur in
ganz bestimmten blasen ist das so die
sind relativ klein also wenn ich eine
wohnung haben möchte ist es immer dass
sich der andere von solchen tag mit
haben wir sagen ja dann sagen die
ungelogen das ist aber kein deutschland
nachgesagt einen doktortitel an sagen
sie okay sie können zum wohnungs
besichtigungstermin kommen also wir
wissen dass wenn es um die möglichkeit
gibt auch nur von ärzten gut behandelt
zu werden und so weiter als all das
spielt hat eine riesige rolle aufgang
armutsrisiko all das irgendwie ist real
da aber in einer pop kultur erst seit
relativ kurzer zeit ich würde sagen
wahrscheinlich seit fünf jahren maximal
zehn jahren das ist ja mich ist es eine
währung geworden und wir haben halt
einfach brown john schwarz sein um
definiert also näher als es wurde als
entmenschlicht definiert und irgendwie
und da gab es ja black is beautiful und
black power und irgendwie und all das
und noch glasmacher
das heißt schwarz sein irgendwann ist
mit widerstand mit aneignung selbst
aneignen und verbindung gebracht waren
während weiß ist einmal definiert wann
dann wurde es unsichtbare als die norm
war und weiß ist als promis sie als
weiße überlegenheit definiert worden und
seitdem nicht mehr angetastet worden
das heißt wenn wir uns auf irgendwelche
theorien über weiß einbeziehen dann sind
es theorien immer weiße überlegenheit
wir müssen natürlich weiß genauso
menschlicher machen
männlich sein menschlicher machen müssen
irgendwie wenn wir weiblich sein
menschlicher machen das natürlich auch
irgendwie dass manche gegen kein
menschlicher machen und da das nicht
passiert ist ist es tatsächlich ein
problem als es gibt ja auch zum beispiel
irgendwie die ganzen theorien über weit
für ziele die ich übrigens sehr sehr
schwierig finde
wir wussten fast wieso den gedanken gibt
aber irgendwie es weiß ein charakter
mangel für preisgenau so menschlich man
hat eine andere position macht an
bestimmten punkten andere erfahrung um
diese erfahrungen zu reflektieren zu
reflektieren was es heißt weiß zu sagen
welche privilegien wie zum beispiel
haben das verlangt auch das was man
kritikern es nennt auch so ein ganz
wichtiges schlagwort joachim gauck der
ehemalige deutsche bundespräsident der
hat in einem beitrag in der zeit
kürzlich geschrieben dass er sieht wie
wichtig es ist gegen rassismus
vorzugehen und die wichtige system für
menschenrechte zu kämpfen
aber das critical wenn es für ihn ein
problem darstellt dass er nämlich den
eindruck hat man würde plötzlich alle
weißen mit kolonialherrschaft in
verbindung bringen oder alle weißen zu
irgendwelchen einen fürsten und
diktatoren machen und dass er doch auch
betonen möchte dass es immer auch weiße
sklaven und sklaven gab zum beispiel im
osmanischen reich gab es ganz viele
weiße sklaven oder auch nicht weiße
sklavenhalter das ist total also es ist
immer ganz ganz schwierig gerade in der
debatte um sklaverei es kommt immer ja
aber es sind auch weißer menschen zu
sklaven machen ich glaube wirklich dass
der transatlantische sklaven eine neue
form von sklaverei war also auch weil es
ja vor die vorstellung ist auch nicht
für sein leben lang sklave sein muss
deshalb zehn jahre sind so lange und
dann kannst kann sich das auch wieder
verändern dass mit dem transatlantischen
sklavenhandel ja hautfarbe plötzlich
superwichtig wurde also es halt weiße
sklaven gegen schwarze sklaven
ausgespielt worden dass die chance als
weißes glas überleben sehr sehr viel
höhere als als schwarzer und das ist das
warum irgendwie wir heute mit dieser
großen last sind an die warum endwert
seien ja aber weiß sein hat ja die
ganzen prüflingen weiß dass claassen hat
uns echt nicht gut aber irgendwie hatten
ein wieso eine leidet und eine lage
darunter und irgendwie und das wurde ja
ex
da eingesetzt um sie gegeneinander
auszuspielen es gibt ja diesen tollen
irgendwie so ein sketch also wo es halt
ein mensch mit zehn keksen gibt einen
mit 1 und 1 ohne und dann sagt er mit
den zehen keksen und die mit dem ein
keks pass auf der andere will dein kicks
wegnehmen und so ein bisschen so
funktioniert das das problem ist und ich
würde dem zustimmen
irgendwie also ich vertrete ja unter
anderem auch in dem buch die theorie
dass die ersten menschen die
kolonialisiert wurden hier die eigenen
sind nun also das irgendwie zum beispiel
schwarz in england im 18 jahrhundert
bedeutete arbeiterklasse nicht da gab's
dann irgendwie artikel darüber die
schwarzen die haben nicht schwarz gesagt
haben dass ein wort verwendet gehen auf
die straßen und es waren arbeiter und
arbeiterinnen kein einziger schwarzer
dabei irgendwie also es war ein klasse
bezogene begriff der erst im 19
jahrhundert mit irgendwie dem
transatlantischen sklavenhandel und so
weiter eine ganz andere bedeutung
bekommen hat und da ging es ganz klar
darum welche menschen sind echte
menschen mit menschenrechten und welche
wenn aus den menschenrechten auch
herausgenommen immer schon immer schon
immer schon und wenn man das sie kann
eine ganz andere solidarität auch
möglich sein das heißt sie kontrolliert
sozusagen gaux erzählung mit den weißen
nahm sklaven und ergänzen das auch ganz
wichtig noch einmal zurück zu dieser
idee der kritiker weiter
was ist konkret verlangt von mir als
weißer personen was heißt es critical
weiters kann jetzt mal in sich
aufzusaugen und zu leben
ich finde es ganz schwierig es gibt
viele sachen an kritiker weiter ist
einfach antirassismus sind die finde ich
großartig der gedanke ich muss mich
jetzt hinsetzen und gucken ob irgendwie
in mir das genuin böses ist weil ich
weiß bin
das finde ich falsch das ist auch nicht
bei allen es gibt ganz viele
unterschiedliche formen von kritiker
weiter
es gibt bestimmte form die so
kolportiert werden diese in die medien
kommen und dazu will ich mich wirklich
von abgrenzt das finde ich auch nicht
hilfreich
also war das bedeutet halt nur dass die
netten antirassistischen weißen im mund
halten und die anderen die donald trumps
und brust johnstons dieser welt
irgendwie werden weiterhin genauso reden
wie sie bisher geredet haben aber und
das ist das aber darin bezeichnung die
alter weißer mann sind ja etwas was
falsches niemand aufgrund von alter
aufgrund von hautfarbe aufgrund von
geschlecht zu diskriminieren ist ja
schrecklich absolut ablehnen es wert
aber es führt dazu dass menschen zum
ersten mal körperlich erleben was ihnen
die ganze versucht wurde zu erklären
also dieses das ist doch und das
wirklich das einmal erlebt zu haben und
sich in dieser form gefühlt zu haben das
macht ganz es gibt einen neuen blick
sollte niemals ein hipper ist dabei
bleiben aber es als als stadium ich
glaube dass es dass es viele sind schon
wirklich erkenntnisgewinn gebracht hat
die man ansonsten herstellen konnte
dieses stadium ist wohl auch sehr
wichtig so endet ja auch das buch in dem
letzten eintrag den die hauptfigur macht
sie ist auch eine bloggerin unter
identität lockt sie schreibt sie über
judith butler und zitiert sie und sagt
es gibt doch etwas was uns verbindet
nämlich die gemeinde die halle sind
verletzlich gewesen und nicht nur das
wir alle können einander lieben und wir
haben ein interesse aneinander ist das
sozusagen das versöhnliche dass sie
denken auf diesem interesse aneinander
da sollte etwas gemeinsames erwachsen
also absolut ich glaube der menschen ich
glaube es nicht ich weiß menschen kann
sowieso nicht ohne einander überleben
und im moment haben wir so
gesamtgesellschaftliche andere
rhetoriker die sind für uns gefährlich
migration ist gefährlich mutter aller
probleme und so weiter und es stimmt ja
nicht wir brauchen uns hat migration
schon immer gegeben irgendwie die sind
nicht anders als wir
die gemeinsamkeiten sind so viel größer
und auf die müssen wir uns beziehen
und irgendwie wir brauchen natürlich
diese form von utopien auch von links
und und das ist halt so dass worauf sie
hinaus ich mag zu des pater die so sind
wie wir teilen unsere verletzlichkeit
das ist ja etwas was ganz stark geändert
und irgendwie ratifiziert wurde das
verletzlichkeit also eine der weiße mann
ist der unverletzlichen und frauen
sollen verletzlich sein angeben braune
menschen sollen 40 an schwarze menschen
sollen verletzt sein
und das wir alle teilen gleichzeitig
teilen wir nicht nur verletzlichkeit zum
vitalen ja freude liebe als wir teilen
auch all diese dinge miteinander
sie haben einmal die frage erhalten was
das eigentlich für ein buch ist und sie
haben die wirklich überraschende antwort
für mich überraschen die antwort gegeben
das sei ein heimatroman ihre heimat
begriff ist ein bunter begriff ist das
auch ihre zukunftsvision lasst uns eine
so bunte welt bewahren weil es noch
kostbarer in
bilder vielleicht ja aber es ging mir
tatsächlich um ort auch ganz viel also
und jesus wie können wir uns in orten
wiederfinden wie können wir auch unseren
wieder erkennen dass es sich eben mit
die kollektiven gedächtnis also eine wie
können wir einen ort auch zu heimat
machen darin wahlheimat ist ja so ein
politisch aufgeladenen begriff der mich
immer gegen menschen verwendet wird
ihnen gehört nicht wirklich echt zur
heimat dazu und zu sagen nein irgendwie
es ist auch ein versuch das dem begriff
heimat ich will dass er als belohnung
definieren also ich hab ich wirklich
gesagt heimat meist ist das toll sollten
dann versuchen wir gemeinsam an diesem
belonging und dieser zugehörigkeit zu
arbeiten vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch ich bedanke mich ja wer
weiter lesen wir verlosen zwei exemplare
schon identität mit einer mail an die
sternstunden gehört eines der bücher
vielleicht bald ihnen in einer woche ist
pfingstsonntag zu dieser sendezeit
zeigen wir einen gottesdienst in zwei
wochen gibt es dann aber wieder
philosophie wolfram eilenberger spricht
mit zwei dissidenten über den tieferen
sinn des widerstands und jetzt gleich
folgt die sternstunde musik über die
bieler fans pegasus ihren erfolg musste
sich hart erkämpfen doch heute sitzt sie
fest im sattel der schweizer
musiklandschaft eine gute zeit für sie
und bis bald
[Musik]